welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz and today
we've got a
different and
exciting episode i'm joined by one of
vinceri's very own i'm joined by ginny
who's going to introduce herself in a
second but for those of you that listen
to this podcast you would have obviously
heard about vincerie and
a number of times i would have told you
about some of the the great career
opportunities at the business the growth
journey they're going on so we thought
it'd be a good idea to jump on with some
of the people at the business
to record a short episode to find out
how these people went from working in
the recruiting industry to them working
for a tech provider to the recruitment
industry and just talk a bit about that
journey what they've learned what they
found difficult was sort of maybe been
unexpected about it
but i'm really excited to be joined by
junior today so before
ginny i'm going to ask you all these
different questions
if you could introduce yourself for
those that may not know who you are and
then we'll get into it
sure hi everyone yep so i'm ginny um
i have been at vincere for a couple of
years now
about two and two and a half years and
before that i worked in recruitment up
in manchester uh for about two years as
well so i joined venturi back in may
2019
um it's been been quite a journey yeah
excited to kind of dive in and tell you
all about it absolutely looking forward
to it so let's just start then i always
like to to start uh here with people
because there's always normally a story
but how
like from what i can see online did you
do a bit of traveling
or like you different places and like
how did you end up in recruitment
yeah i did do a fair bit of traveling i
did um yeah a good stint of kind of
running off around the world having a
lovely time asia australia all sorts of
great things and then it was kind of
time to come back to reality with a bit
of a bump um moved up to manchester
there was no real reasoning behind it
being manchester i actually looked on a
map shut my eyes and kind of went out
and just pointed at the map and atlanta
manchester so that was it got on a train
and
i think
a lot of people
i hear a lot of people say that they act
that they kind of don't mean to go into
recruitment i was the opposite i
actually actively sought it out
the reason being was i wanted to have
opportunities to get back out to asia
and i thought okay well what can i do
that's global what can i do that i can
really get my teeth into in the uk but
will eventually perhaps take me abroad
and that kind of got me to recruitment
so i took my first job up in manchester
in 2017
for kind of a big national recruiter um
and that was that was where it all
started really
but it looks like you managed to achieve
that goal and until you joined venturi
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
yeah i
managed a couple of years in the uk and
then and then ended up back out in asia
and yeah i've kind of been back and
forth but it's all good fun yeah for
sure so
tell us tell us a bit about that like
interested to talk a bit about well
let's go into it like because then
obviously the question really is like
okay so that's where you started wanting
to be an environment which could
potentially take you internationally
recruitment can absolutely do that i
think that's one of the great things
that the recruitment industry can do
so how how did you then end up working
for vincerie then
and then we can go into you going over
to singapore
yeah so it was again it was kind of it
was kind of by accident really i um
was done with manchester i wanted to be
back over in asia so i started looking
at recruitment jobs over in um bangkok
in singapore in hong kong
and was taking my off myself off on
holiday over there to do some interviews
um but at the time i was actually
working for um a company who's actually
now one of our clients up in manchester
and they said oh our software company
they're actually based over in saigon
how would you feel about saigon would
you consider a move out of recruitment
um and they put me forward for an
interview at venturi so
i wasn't really looking for it um i was
going over to to stay in recruitment and
then this opportunity just kind of
got put in front of me i went for an
interview met kind of eloise and
everyone and yeah the rest is kind of
history it was it was then kind of a
clear choice of
yeah this is this is the right move
having a team there awesome and then so
you started in
saigon which is their headquarters right
yeah so i started out in the saigon
office i was there for my first year at
vincerie um yeah kind of a lot of people
there
a lot of different teams are based in
that office it's a great place to start
because you can see everything through
from development right through from you
know the product being designed
there's sales guys there cs guys there
there's a bit of everything so it's a
really cool office to just absorb
everything plus you're out in vietnam so
you've got you know all of those perks
as well you know you've got year-round
sunshine and all of all of that fun
stuff as well and great to kind of
still keep that bit of me that wanted to
be
having that element of traveling an
element of not just being
you know here here still in manchester
so it was it was good yeah what was
talk to me like what's uh
what's been the draw like why why are
you why do you have such a gravity
pulled towards
being an abroad interest
um
i think
traveling out there for a couple of
years beforehand i wasn't quite ready to
say goodbye to
that life of going off and doing all of
that travelling yeah but equally i
wanted the career
so
it was i was kind of torn and then i
mean now i just i can't believe my luck
that i managed to kind of get both from
it where i was able to
work in different offices globally for a
company that's you know got the ability
to let you to do that
while still really finding my feet in my
career so to be able to have both of
those was was great
because yeah i wasn't quite ready to say
goodbye to uh that kind of slightly wild
lifestyle of living somewhere a bit
different sure sure and then tell me
about i know obviously it's crazy times
at the moment but like
as i mentioned obviously vincero's
headquarters is there or a big big um
part of their team is like what is that
actually like working in that culture
not ramen out of interest what's that
actually
working now
it's really interesting i mean it's
different obviously but there are i mean
there are so many different
nationalities and backgrounds that work
at victory in all of the offices but
especially so in the in the vietnam
office
um there's just people from worldwide
who are there so it's really really
interesting and there's people from
all sorts of different backgrounds a lot
of ex-recruiters but also people
bringing experience from other uh
backgrounds as well and it's just it
just keeps it really interesting and
there's always kind of different stories
and different perspectives on things
yeah i love that
so talk to us a bit about because it is
it is quite it is quite a popular move
in terms of
sort of being a recruitment professional
and then
sort of considering your options and
actually going down
the route of staying in the industry but
then working with companies that
sell to the recruiting industry it's
just quite a sort of popular transition
so i think obviously a lot of people and
i'm sure you obviously were having some
of these thoughts like how is that
going to actually work like the skills i
have currently are they transferable but
talk to us a bit about from what i can
see it looks like went into customer
success and then you've sort of
progressed into a different role but
like how what was the sort of process or
how was you feeling about taking that
transition out of interest like share
with us some of the positives maybe some
of the challenges around that
sure so it's definitely a challenge so
whilst having the recruitment experience
definitely helps and there are a lot of
transferable skills which i'll talk
about in a sec but
it does come with its challenges as well
but that's exciting right it's it's
still a
while it's still kind of linked to the
industry it is still you know moving
from uh recruitment into rec tech um but
that means that it's really exciting and
you can bring those skills over
um so things like obviously when you're
in recruitment and you're dealing with
hiring managers all day long you're
speaking to business owners
none of that's really changing you know
i'm still speaking every day to business
owners um you're still kind of making
use of those account management skills
so like you said i went into the
customer success team so very much
focused on
consultatively helping our clients and
that's what recruiters are doing as well
right they're just they're just helping
their their clients find candidates and
the flip side here is we're still
helping our clients it's just that the
recruiters and our clients so
we're still kind of bringing kind of
using those same skills
and it's just really really consultative
and just helping them get the most out
of vincerie
um but it's definitely
taught me
not to be i suppose scared of that
industry switch because there are so
many links to it
um
and
you know it can be a bit nerve-wracking
and you're moving to a new you know
potentially a new country a new
continent um
but there are still so many elements of
it which it's really helped me having
that recruitment experience really yeah
um see it's just it's just a really
exciting new challenge really yeah yeah
no um i love that and i guess what what
what's maybe surprised you then so far
and i'm sure you felt positive about
making the move and things like that but
maybe maybe some of the skills or
experiences that you've had that you've
been surprised that you've had or you
didn't expect to have
taught us a bit about that
yeah i suppose just how many
transferable skills i've been able to
bring over um so i was kind of
anxious of it being this massive change
you know i've never worked in tech
before i wouldn't class myself as a
terribly techy person i never have done
um so
i was a bit kind of like anxious of that
wary of that but actually being able to
bring that knowledge of okay i've sat in
the recruiter shoes i've done it i've
actually i used vincerie as a customer
right so
i've literally been sat in their shoes
being shown this new product um so being
able to bring that it's kind of
surprised me how big an impact that has
had and how much that has really helped
me
what are
what are recruiters like as customers
i mean this is my wide resolution
i know they can definitely definitely
they can definitely hit and miss that's
for sure
it's interesting let's just say no to no
two days the same no two clients are the
same um
it's very much you know it's a
fast-paced industry right everyone
everyone who's gonna listen to this
knows that the recruitment is so
fast-paced they want to be they've
they've got clients who want something
now therefore from us they need stuff
they need stuff now they want to know
kind of how it works the best way to use
it
so
it's fast-paced um you know dealing with
recruiters it's always it's always going
to be interesting um but you know again
it's that thing of i've been there i've
done it i can see things from their
point of view
um which again i think really really
helps i've been sat in their shoes and i
can help them you know this is this is
how we can
uh you know make venturi work for you
this is how this can get help you get
the most out of your business
okay
yeah i think so yeah some good days and
bad days maybe with recruiters customers
but overall good as you said i think
it is it is like it just goes such a
long way i felt like when people know
that you've been in their shoes or like
you really understand their challenges
and or how the sort of problems they
have and the solutions that um they want
so
okay talk to me talk to me a bit about
like
obviously your journey from the stamp
like what's been
your perspective of like being a like
part of the vincero team and in the last
two years seeing this little journey or
being part of the journey it's been on
like from your point of views what have
you been i guess most surprised about in
terms of like vince vince areas as a
business and it seems like
they they're just really on this great
trajectory of
like just positive growth and
have some great customers have loads of
people saying great things about them
constantly innovating i think they've
got obviously this amazing opportunity
that they have a huge amount of their
team in obviously vietnam and like so i
don't know like what's been your
perspective
of like vincerie the vincero journey so
far
since you've been yeah i mean you kind
of
hit the nail on the head there by saying
that they're always innovating that is a
huge part of it
um the product is always developing it's
always changing and that's really
exciting and it means that we can always
kind of bring things out for our
customers
and what you know what they want and
what they need um but kind of being on
the inside and seeing it seeing it grow
over the last kind of two two and a half
years
the growth has just been phenomenal i
mean the the kind of change internally
from
uh you know being a relatively small
team um you know just kind of managing
managing apac from a customer success
perspective
and now kind of watching you know the
london team grow so drastically the
saigon team the sydney team
every team is growing so rapidly and
people just have to be so agile
we have to be on a daily basis just
really flexible and willing to change
the kind of the way that we're working
the way that we look at things but it's
really exciting and you can really feel
it internally this
kind of growth that we're all going
through um you can just kind of feel it
in the air like every everyone is
excited about what's what's coming um
and just i mean just looking at the
growth over the last year and the last
two years since i've been here it's it's
just huge and it's just a really
exciting atmosphere and just a really
exciting time for the company yeah and
obviously that that obviously obviously
presents this opportunities internally
right so how it's obviously started in
customer success
so then you move back to london that
looks like
yeah right yeah so i was in customer
success over in saigon so i was kind of
heading up the apac region there looking
after our customers um based in asia
and then after a year base there moved
back to london um there's just the
timing was right really so i moved back
over to london
and was doing the same role for our uk
and emir customers
and then
about two months ago moved into my
current role which is head of
implementations
which is much more focused on
kind of rather than existing customers
and sort of the looking after of them
it's customers who are
freshly on board they
aren't live yet and it's kind of looking
after them through that period it can be
quite painful
that period yeah i mean it's never it's
never the most first of all it's not the
most exciting bit because they just want
to be live right yeah so it's kind of
it's this bit that has to be done
they're bringing over the data but it's
such a key stage um making sure that you
know all of their data is coming over
from their old site and so on so it's a
really important
kind of period and just being able to
project manage that bit of time and make
sure that they're happy and make sure
everything's running smoothly
it's a really kind of exciting role to
be in
so yeah kind of move through those three
different roles and again it just ties
in with what i was saying about the
rapid growth but also how agile
everything is here like things are
always moving and we are adapting
internally to be able to
you know kind of satisfy what our
customers need because of that fast
growth
sure and then
just because i think customer success
can be like a really great transition
for
recruiters that do want to get into tech
because of the transferable skills so
talk to the if you don't mind you did a
really good job there of talking about
you know what being head of
implementation means or what you're in
charge of like what what did a typical
day look like as a customer success
manager of interest
sure so cs yeah like you said it is a
great role to come over from recruitment
because that's where i would say a lot
of the similarities lie
um because you are talking to those key
decision makers every day also those key
kind of heart
managers i should say yeah um you're
speaking to them about how best to how
they can best
kind of get what they need out of in
cherry
um you know what's right for one
customer isn't necessarily going to be
right for another so it's very
consultative
and ultimately those are all skills
which you're using as a recruiter on a
day-to-day basis right you're always
consulting with your with your hiring
managers
um
about your candidates so there's a lot
of transferable skills that can come
over but day to day yep you're talking
to
those key kind of directors and managers
your training end users on how to
actually use the product um you're
dealing with kind of ad hoc things that
come up so whether it's kind of things
on people's accounts whether it's
something to do with more like a
contract side of things
um
there's all sorts of things that could
come up um but it's very much a role for
people who are wanting to still have
that consultative approach with people
and be able to ultimately just help them
get what they need out of the system and
that's kind of what the cs team is all
about we we want to enable our customers
to be able to to achieve what they need
to achieve yeah absolutely
so why why didn't you tell us like so
from your experience then like what
would your
advice or thoughts be for anyone that
was like
potentially open to a move into the tech
industry and as as we've just discussed
like that recruitment experience can be
really valuable
to transfer into
working for working in rec tech so like
what what advice or what thoughts would
you give to anyone that is considering
making a transitional move into red tech
yeah i'd say
be hungry for it the opportunities are
huge um
i mean i've i came into a cs position
and now i'm in a in a kind of
like a different team there are
opportunities internally um there's so
many different parts to it whether it's
cs whether it's sales whether it's on
the product side development there are
so many different avenues that you can
take internally so if you're hungry for
progression and you're hungry to make a
difference and have a voice in a company
it's a great industry in general to be
in but specifically eventually
you can really make an impact and that's
really exciting that's kind of one of
the biggest things that i've enjoyed
over the last couple of years is being
able to
bring what i've learned in the past um
and be able to actually have a voice
with that and make an impact and make
changes yeah you can't you can't be
feeling recognized or like having ideas
and then seeing them actually
uh happen in in in the business that you
work for
yeah absolutely and it's yeah it's
exciting so so as we finish this up then
like i know you're just mentioning it
there but what's on there
what's on the horizon for vincero then
why is it an exciting time have you got
any
i don't know ins like maybe uh secrets
you can tell us or maybe not not tell us
that much about it i'm not trying to
call now like what i might have to if i
might have to kill you if i told you
that yeah no
um no there is you know that we're not
out of this growth period we're very
much still on the way up um i mean
specifically we're looking for people
globally at the moment so we've got a
rollover in the u.s that we're looking
for um anyone who's wanting to be based
out of atlanta so that's very exciting
uh kind of growing uh growing a team
there we're also looking for people all
the time in london saigon sydney
um ibiza so
there's always stuff going on um and
yeah it's it's definitely not over we
definitely haven't peaked yet there's
still a long way to go and we are just
we're always just excited to hear from
people who want to be a part of that and
they want to kind of come on that
journey and like i said if you're hungry
for it
and you are kind of willing to get stuck
in and want to get your hands dirty and
want to progress it's a great place to
be yeah no i mean i've i've been to
europe i've been to offices in uh
liverpool streets great location
and i feel like one of the one of the
really cool things as well about working
in rec tech is like also one of the
things that you might feel like you'd
miss in recruitment is that
like the the people element and i know
some people have had some terrible
experience and someone's like the people
they've worked with or the cultures
they've been part of but a lot of the
time
most recruiters would go you know what i
absolutely loved that sort of office
environment i loved the sort of socials
we had and i think that's one of the
things that you can you can definitely
get like when i walked into your office
it's just like you've also got that
unique feeling of like
it's it's obvious it's not a recruitment
company but you've got that sort of
culture fill and vibe that you'd expect
in a uh recruitment business which is a
big part of what we all enjoy about it
so yeah absolutely it's not like a big
it's not a big corporate machine it's
very much you know it's a nice place to
be they said they're lovely offices but
he also everyone here is just decent
everyone's just decent people so um it's
it's really like it's a nice place to
come into every day and like you said
nice offices and everything kind of
obviously helps with that absolutely
well uh ginny thank you so much for
coming on
you're welcome excited to yeah see you
obviously where you are in another two
years vincero i've been cherries another
two years so as junior mentioned really
exciting time i've been cherry so if
you wanted any further questions i know
junior be more than happy to connect
with you on linkedin but at the same
time in in the show notes of this
episode you'll be able to check out what
uh ventura have going on at the moment
so make sure you do that but ginny
thanks for uh coming on the pod
no thank you thank you for having me